quasi totalité des dé martinique et les
résidents de ville il reste environ 30
personnes a débarqué sur les 400 qui
était prévu à cette escale
quelles sont les consignes précises on
voit qu'un a qui partent en voiture y en
a qui partent en bus comment ça se passe
alors en fait il ya une évaluation qui a
été fait il ya un auto-questionnaire une
prise de température systématique un
entretien avec un médecin à la sortie il
ya deux personnes qui ont été d'ailleurs
identifier combien de la température et
qui ont déjà été dirigé vers le chu pour
les autres personnes il ya des mesures
de confinement pendant 14 jours
donc selon en fait l'organisation du
foyer familial le confinement il peut
être fait à la maison je rappelle que
c'est important de le dire que jusqu'à
preuve du contraire c'est des gens qui
n'ont rien qui ne sont pas malades c'est
pas des pestiférés
c'est des gens qu'on met en surveillance
simplement pendant 14 jours parce que'il
on était sur un bateau où il ya eu deux
cas le coronavirus et donc il est
donc il est extrêmement important que
qui ne soit pas considérée dans les
villes où ils ont rentré comme ayant
ayant coronavirus c'est pas le cas
pendant 14 jours et qui vont être
surveillées dont soit c'est des gens qui
habitent un couple qui habite
donc ça c'est des gens qui sont 2 qui
habitent ensemble bien ils ont des
mesures de confinement à domicile
pendant 14 jours ils vont rester chez
eux on leur a fourni des masques et ils
vont surveiller leur température on les
appellera deux fois par jour pour
certaines personnes l'hébergement chez
eux était pas possible soit parce qu'il
ya des personnes fragiles au domicile
parce qu'il ya des enfants etc
donc on a mis en place un centre